the iPhone 15 has officially leaked not
just some cads renders an actual photo
of the iPhone 15 is here and it confirms
something massive something of apple has
never done before in its history but
before I explain exactly what I'm
talking about I've got to show you guys
this image it's a Mac Rumors exclusive
right here we have the full iPhone 15
design with some major major changes but
it's missing some others this is
actually from unknowns 21 or you
redditor on Twitter you can see him
right here definitely follow him because
his leaks are legit I don't know how he
gets his sources but he is very very
good and you can see his leak right here
now first thing we see the front of the
iPhone 15 and on the bottom we we see
the USB type-c port so yes finally
lightning is going away across the board
with the iPhone 15 lineup USB type-c but
there is a catch which I'm going to
explain in just a second but the biggest
deal you have to realize in this image
is that the chassis is no longer
redesigned yes we can see the dynamic
Island right up here finally we're
getting rid of a notch finally that
thing has to go and it is with the
iPhone 15 however if you look at the
outside edges they are exactly the same
as the current iPhone 14 and that's a
big deal because we're expecting a full
redesign for the 15 lineup but it's
actually only on the 15 Pro Models and
unknowns 21 leaked an actual image of
the 15 Pro and the big difference there
is that the edges are actually curved
not completely flat like the iPhone 14.
now all of this matches up to something
that minchiklo said back in September
saying that with the iPhone 15 lineup
apple is gonna further separate their
devices with different features and if
you've been following means you quote on
Twitter you'll know what some of those
are for example he mentioned that all of
them are going to have USBC however only
the high-end models are gonna have
faster transfer speeds like potentially
even Thunderbolt while the regular
iPhone 15 is going to be limited to USB
2.0 which is insanely slow that's so
disappointing also he did mention that
the new iPhone 15 Pro Models are gonna
have basically solid state buttons no
more physical buttons but that is
actually not coming to the regular
iPhone 15 only to the Pro Models but
before I get into that I've got to talk
about the best iPhone case I've ever
seen the magic stand case from our
partner case Q not only is it
surprisingly slim and durable but it
comes with a very strong 48 Magnet Max
safe ring that actually doubles as a
stand just pull out the ring and use it
as a finger grip or a stand for watching
videos at any angle between 40 and 120
degrees and the best part is that it
folds back completely flush with the
case so you can still use it with your
max save charger and accessories so
check out the link in the discount info
in the video description below now this
new leak from unknowns 21 goes
completely against what shrimp Apple Pro
is saying because he said it would have
the same kind of design with the curved
edges and everything else with him
saying the design language is going to
be on the vanilla 15 as well but unowns
21 does not agree especially with that
leak you just shared now he is reliable
because because he did mention that
Wi-Fi 6E will only be on the 15 Pro
Models not on the iPhone 15 and then of
course here is the image of the 15 Pro
with the new titanium finish and the
curve going towards the display which is
not coming on the iPhone 15. so for the
first time ever with Apple's iPhone
lineup apple is completely
differentiating the design from the
regular models and the Pro Models it's
completely different so later this year
the iPhone 15 is going to be boring it's
going to have the old design for a lower
price and the brand new awesome design
with all the features is only coming on
the 15 Pro and the best part about
unknown's 21's leaks is that they match
up to the official cads that Max winebox
shared with nine to five Mac they match
up perfectly and they do show the a
curve towards the side kind of blending
into the glass with a crazy camera bump
they also show how it's going to be more
rounded and more comfortable like Ian
Zelda showed and his renders that he's
working on also they show the 2.5 D
front glass with shrimp Apple Pro showed
off kind of like the Apple watch where
it's flat and then it gets kind of cut
down into the side and Blended and you
can see how massive the camera bump is
going to be but keep in mind that's only
on the 15 Pro the regular 15 is gonna
have a much smaller camera bump and then
Ian of course showed off these nice
titanium textures and of course that's
only coming on the pro not the 15. this
is so disappointing apple is
differentiating these models like never
before which to me means that the
regular 15 is going to be the same price
again no price hike eight hundred
dollars well I think the 15 Pro is going
to get even more expensive and you can
just hear a list of features that the 15
pro and pro Max are getting like for
example 120hz promotion not on the 15.
new design 2.5 D glass not on the 15
thinner bezels not on the 15. titanium
frame solid state buttons Periscope and
the Promax the new a17 chip three
nanometer eight gigs of RAM Wi-Fi 6E
Thunderbolt 3 none of those features are
coming on the 15 and basically this is
the first time that Apple has ever done
this and it's absolutely insane to see
the real image of the iPhone 15 already
in February right here in front of us
and it's not getting the redesign and oh
my goodness guys you will not believe
this Max Weinbach as I'm filming this
just released new iPhone 15 cads yes
official cads for the iPhone 15 have
been released and apparently the iPhone
15 is going to be a little bit larger
6.2 inches instead of 6.1 and take a
look at these cats ads you can see the
15 Pro on the left the 15 on the right
Dynamic Island just as we expected
before and oh my goodness the 15 Pro
Camera buff is gonna be massive it looks
like it's basically the same on the
iPhone 15 on the left and there you go
that right there is going to give you a
huge difference in camera quality look
at that the iPhone 15 camera bump is
small compared to the 15 Pro now maybe
it's getting quite a bit bigger but
compared to the 15 Pro it's tiny and you
can see USBC on both of them but the
craziest thing here is that according to
Max Weinbach and these cads apparently
the new design language almost looks
like it is coming because this does look
kind of rounded it's hard to tell in
these cads maybe it hasn't changed at
all in terms of how the glass works and
if it's 2.5 D or not but it does kind of
look rounded I guess we'll have to wait
and see for confirmation if you're
waiting for the iPhone 15 line up you
better try to save up some money right
now so you could get the Pro Models
because these things are kind of gonna
suck yes of course they have USBC they
have the dynamic Island but they are
going to be so much worse than the Pro
Models apple is going to make everyone
want the pro and I'm gonna recommend
that model for sure so hopefully you
enjoy these leaks from unknowns 21 let
me know what you think down in the
comment section below and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign